we're gonna talk a little bit more about
Blizzcon right now um there have been
other leaks and rumors starting with
these preview gift bags that were sent
to Blizzcon attendees it's sold out now
but you can pay $40 to watch it
digitally I don't know how that even
works like wouldn't just go to twitch or
something I don't think it's on twitch
oh okay well that's why how the $40
works uh yeah these like four-sided die
were released and if you like look at it
right it's one one one four it's like
eleven like November fourth whatever or
one one four I left November 4th and a
lot of people also took that as meaning
Diablo 4 and also people thought that
Diablo 4 is overdue now Diablo 3
released in 2012 obviously it took about
12 years after - I was gonna say that
math yeah I was like at this rate we're
gonna get it in what 2026 or something
like I don't know why I don't know it's
but I guess I want to take the time
regardless of what we know or don't know
I want to talk about like in an ideal
world just let's be completely crazy
what Blizzard game you would want them
to announce if they were to announce a
full game erekt a would be I think I'd
be excited for Diablo 4 although part of
me keeps thinking cause like we I've
been on that speculative rumor chain of
like oh is it Diablo for because of the
dice or this other stuff and I wanted
the AH before I just don't know how they
evolved past Diablo 3 like they found
this like really nice common ground for
Diablo 3 where it was not only
accessible on PC but also on console the
console port version was very good I
think you can agree with that Mike and
yeah I'm interested to see if that is
the case what where they go from there
because they have to make it not just
like the elbow three Diablo 2 right to
make get people to play obviously and
there are other games out there that
have kind of tried to take like a Diablo
style game would evolve it a little bit
so like I've been wanting to play
lineage to eternal which is done by
NCsoft it's pretty much like Diablo but
like an MMO version of Diablo where a
lot of the skill sets a lot of the moves
and all
mechanically are just like Diablo like
if you were playing in a RPG but then
there's like bigger world events where
you might run into ten other people and
like fight like a world boss or
something like that but still in a very
Diablo style mechanical combat type
style whatever but if it's not that then
like the only other things that they
could really announced that Blizzcon for
like a new game in terms of like older
IPs would be warcraft 4 yes it's been
yeah forever yeah that's what you had
mentioned me before the lobby
yeah like Starcraft is sort of carried
you know the RTS helm for them but I
feel like Starcraft is kind of like
we're nets course for the moment so what
better way to actually bring Warcraft
back to the masses because not everyone
wants to play World of Warcraft not
everyone wants to watch that movie give
them what they what they love give them
you know where Warcraft began like I
used to love playing those games and I
just don't care for the MMO and so I
would love to see Warcraft 4 and I feel
like for their team that's been working
in such a dark you know dark RTS series
to make something more lighthearted
would be a good opportunity for them
creatively did you play a lot of three
I'm gonna swimming then yeah a lot of
three but mostly two two is where I
really cut my teeth yeah I was three for
me and then actually I still up until
last year was playing Warcraft 3 mods
they had winter mall for tower defense
that we played all the time and that's
actually what introduced me to tower
defense games which I really like now so
like the weirdest sub-genre I get into a
lot yeah I did like 100% be on board for
Warcraft four I kind of trailed off with
Starcraft 2 with hardest swarm wings of
Liberty and legacy the legacy the void I
didn't really get into legacy the void
at all I played a little hard to swarm I
was kind of looking for an excuse to get
back in and I'm obviously expansions
were that exact excuse but I just didn't
at the time and for as much as I loved
Starcraft 2 like Warcraft four would
definitely kind of satiate my like RTS
cravings lately I don't know what you
would mention like what I just I I could
see there being a Warcraft four
but they're worried about okay they're
worried partially I think with Warcraft
for where do they go with the story in
terms of Warcraft because it also has to
like it also has to somehow work out
with World of Warcraft right so that's
one problem and two let's kind of be
real like this is something I've been
I always want to make a make a video
here at GameSpot about for like the last
half a year I just never got around to
doing it is that like I feel like RTS as
a genre is just falling off like
severely like there aren't very many RTS
games I've come out and if they do they
don't generally do that well write you
this year there were a few and they
score well yeah I can see your point
maybe they're not selling but I guess
where I see differently is that if
Blizzard released another RTS they'd
have no problem I don't think Starcraft
2 was anything less than a success for
them yeah if you like you know
especially if you look at what they're
what they're currently doing they're
trying so many new things how great
would it be to actually be like but hey
we haven't forgotten our roots you know
we're still the company that we were
when you guys you know became fans I
think that could earn them like more
more you know more customers then say a
game that's trying to follow in the
footsteps of some military RTS sure that
leads me to the next rumor also that
like Diablo 2 remake wasn't know works
you wouldn't be into that no I don't see
the point I mean today at Eric's point 3
felt very much like the logical
conclusion to what 2 is trying to do
took it into some new places as well I
don't know what I would want like from a
Diablo 4 I'm not even sure what I would
want but to see Diablo 2 again would
just kind of be like oh ok especially
after the wait for Diablo 3 right to
just immediately bring it back yeah like
that I couldn't do that I couldn't get
excited about that well you had brought
up an interesting point about recent
Blizzard games being kind of you know
people wonder if they're designed to
like later down the road be able to be
played on consoles obviously Diablo 3 is
just got the five ability keys on the
keyboard and then obviously that
translates well to a controller where
you can dodge the right stick move to
the left and then do your basic attack
with X and then the triggers and the
face buttons but how would Diablo 2
remake translate over like without them
just saying no we're only doing PC would
that even work I don't know how they do
that that's like a remake and not just
yeah yeah like I because I think about
this all the time I talk to Julio a lot
because we played a lot of Diablo 2
together we played a lot of Diablo 3
together and then thinking about like
not just yell before but if it was a
remastered like that doesn't seem like
it'd be that great for them because I'm
like
how do they get it on the console it
seems like they want it you know there's
more more consumers if you can have it
on both obviously right and with the ps4
Pro coming out and xbox slim though you
know like all that all these things are
there for them to try to get it on - but
Diablo 2 had such a big skill tree and
has so many potential combination of
buttons that like I just don't see how
you fit that onto a controller so is it
just PC is that good enough I don't know
and that like just on the remastered
point what if it was just warcraft 3 or
warcraft - remastered and not a warcraft
4 mmm cuz I thought they were gonna do
that last year when they had the 20th
anniversary and they didn't do it so I
mean you can still buy Warcraft 3 right
and that game yeah you can still use
your GPU to make it look a little bit
better than maybe it did back in the day
- would be weird to remake just because
it's groans you know our tastes have
grown so much the other speculation is
also Starcraft and brood war remaster
which was like a rumor for a while now
so weird I mean there have been a ton of
remasters this year alone and we're
talking about Skyrim in the next segment
and then remastered in general in the
last but pleasures never done a remaster
have they for anything like that's not
their thing they just do something new
and a completely new genre and then
knock it out of the park unfortunately
you know what their thing is is eSports
yeah right outside of Diablo that's
pretty much their focus right so if they
were even to me it's like a wider object
I'm just realizing if they're gonna try
to make warcraft 4 how would that ever
fit into an eSports thing when Starcraft
clearly figured it out
I mean to be fair I'm sure they I don't
know much yeah it's kind of like giving
them the benefit of that doubt I guess
but I don't know I wouldn't see the
Warcraft formula like you said that as
it exists with one two three kind of
translating into any sports arena would
be so weird like overwatch obviously
does really well Starcraft does
Starcraft is like the game I think about
when I think of eSports decided I'm like
MOBAs I don't know we're frantic right
like it needs that ceiling
yeah it's skill ceiling I don't know but
that even that is kind of dwindling as
you had mentioned earlier so in terms of
Starcraft as an eSport it's kind of
going down for them a little bit they've
already like Korea already pulled out
they're not even doing their pro league
anymore I believe so well isn't a rush
the number one game like yeah
the last point I want to touch on in
relation to Diablo 4 still is that just
this morning an update to our Sombra
article Reddit user John Kennedy Toole
which is an interesting name that's the
author of confederacy of dunces I don't
know sorry discovered that Blizzard site
may have also leaked new Diablo 3
necromancer art which would suggest a
new class for Diablo 3 a 7th class and
which is weird they show we expect is up
on our story and it I don't know where
I'm assuming it was just like in this
server something like right there you
can see him what's interesting with the
the graphic here though is that there is
a female and male right necromancer so
do are they doing the remastered like
special edition Diablo 2 or now you can
pick either female or man right or is
this maybe Diablo 3 expansion like a 7th
class yeah it's also weird though I mean
like I've played I have 6 level 70
characters on console and I'm pretty
close on PC for Diablo 3 I played that
game I still play that game every once
in a while and I have nothing else to
play the witch doctor kind of fills out
some of the necromancer yes like a lot
of them and I wouldn't be too psyched
about a 7th class I feel like they they
kind of nailed it they have three mid to
long range characters and then they have
three close up kind of tank --is--
characters sorry like three close range
characters the monks not a tanks more of
a glass cannon but I don't know I don't
see the necromancer fitting in I don't
see Hwanhee and expansion for three as
much as I love that game imagine the fan
reception there just down some more
Diablo 3 I think they would get booed
probably well I would I would boo them
but I would also be super psyched that I
haven't at least a play more secretly
also fun fact though is that I find it
hard to believe that it's Diablo 3
related because the game director Josh
mascara he had just recently left like
in the last three to six months and you
would think that if it was a Diablo 3
thing that he would probably be on board
for that part of it or he left because
he didn't like the direction they were
taking yeah
I'm gonna go with Diablo for Diablo 2
remastered I don't see this as an
expansion all right Bob Jones and chat
on twitch is that saying Mike asked
about Starcraft 3 or a Starcraft
first-person shooter ghost yeah though
the cancelled one way they handled 164
they brought that back
what if they brought titan and goes back
eventually I would be dead didn't I say
the work went into overwatch yeah Titan
like when it over watches what Titan
began as or sorry overwatch is like the
end product of Titan development one
night your overwatch is like the PvP
mode in Titan or something like that's
pretty good that's a mode this is one
small Titan I would love a Starcraft MMO
never gonna happen
I've always wanted it there's a time
where I thought I was being really smart
and I was like oh I'm gonna buy the web
the web address space of StarCraft
because it's gonna be like World of
Warcraft right and then somebody had it
and then I was just like alright
somebody was smarter than me obviously
someone someone at Blizzard just pissed
their pants and heard you say that say
oh my god SOS what if it's VR related
we're gonna do some wacky VR thing what
if they're like they just decided to
lead a charge into like full-on VR and
so everybody else does too and just that
I don't know working ghost comes out in
VR it's a bold move
I think we've exhausted the well of
possibilities from Blizzcon again post
cons November 4th and the Erte you're
going down you're gonna be there on
Friday and Saturday yeah no and for just
like interviews and whatnot the next day
with Justin hey Walt yeah pretty much
you guys will be kind of like watching
here and and doing like quicker
reactions so stay tuned for that
obviously like the big announcements
we'll also see if maybe sombras
available to play someone here will
probably live stream that if it is if
not you'll get our impressions from
Blizzcon and yeah they're you know
Justin will do his thing and I'll tag
along and I'll get to walk around and
hang out cool yeah we'll be talking a
lot about Blizzcon like you said my
fingers across for Diablo 4 so here's
hoping let us know what you think what
you want from Blizzard whether it's
realistic or not let us know in the
comments below